Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
January 11th, 2016 what's
going on? How are Ya?
Oh, is it going? I'm in a great
fucking mode. I don't know why.
You know what? I haven't boozed in like
fucking, I don't know what it's been.
I don't t nine 10 days
or something like that.
I did have a sip of wine last night,
but I don't really consider that Busan,
you know, the way I go after it. Um,
my wife's so, you know, something was
funny when I, when I stopped drinking,
my wife always tries to
get me back to drinking,
not to get drunk or anything. She just
is like, you're so fucking, you know,
I drive her so fucking nuts
that I just think sometimes,
you know, if she wasn't
such a good person,
I think she would try and like drug me
every night like around supper. Right.
Make a little dinner and be like,
how is that honey? Oh, look at you.
You look sleepy. Like I have no idea.
Like, she just put some shit in my food,
not to like kill me, just
to sort of sedate me. Um,
but, uh, anyways, she bought, I haven't
drank in like 10 days or something. Wow.
That really made my head go somewhere
like, wow, that's Kinda fucked up.
She does that. Um, but yeah, I
haven't drank in like 10 days.
I, uh, I'm feeling good and that,
so what happens is nice slowly,
you know, I start to eat better. I'm
starting my day off with the old, uh,
from the old country thing, you know,
little fucking water at room temperature,
which should make you keg if you're any
kind of a fucking human being. But, uh,
you get used to it with some lemon and
then a little cayenne pepper in it.
And then I take a, I
let that settle in me.
Then I get a couple of
scoops of a Greek yogurt,
the all natural stuff that actually
kind of tastes like sour cream.
And the first time I ate it, I was like,
this is the worst shit I've ever
tasted because I was used to the, uh,
the crack baby yogurt that I've been
eating my whole life that has like fucking
40 bags of sugar in it, you know,
and you yogurt, you're like, yeah,
I mean,
the amount of sugar that's in fucking
regular yogurt humani you should fucking
snort it. I mean, it's literally like,
I mean, I'm not gonna lie to you.
I still fucking love it. But, uh,
the Greek shit took me a minute and
now I'm actually, uh, I like it, man.
If I drink this shit and just
have a couple scoops of that,
it kind of fills me up. And, um,
that's kind of the big thing is you
become an old fuck like me. It's just,
just somehow getting the hunger to go
away without doing damage to yourself,
you know,
and then walking around and burning a
few calories before you go to the next
one. You know, and I know
this sponge, you know,
hopefully some younger listeners listening
to this judging Makos and this old
far talking about fucking lemon water,
Cayenne pepper and fucking Greek yogurt.
Well, you know something. If you're
lucky enough, you'll live long enough.
If we don't fuck up something or
something bad doesn't happen to you. A,
you know, to get to by age and you know,
it's good to start healthy
habits now. Fuck. Shut up bill.
What do you the fucking first lady,
you know what I'm doing right now?
I'm doing shit that like a first
lady does right now. I'm actually,
let's get in shape. Kids,
how about you go outside for 10 minutes
a day and you just do some jumping
jacks? Can you fucking believe
that they've got to tell
kids to go out and play?
You know,
that's how fucking insane
video games have got.
I mean,
if I made video games and I actually
saw Michelle Obama on TV begging kids to
try to not have their first
cardiac incident by the
time they were in the third
grade, I mean I, I would tear
up and just be like, I did it.
You know, I am so fucking great at my job.
I've made children stop playing outside,
you know.
Do you think there's like at the Alec
Baldwin of the video gaming industry,
you know, from Glengarry Glen Ross
Ross coming in just screaming at him,
you know, how many kids I cause
to have a heart attack? Seven,
fuck Yo. She's screaming at him
trying to get them to,
we haven't done our fucking jobs til
every kid has a fucking pacemaker by the
seventh grade. Um, I dunno.
Anyways. Yeah. So I'm trying
to get back in shape. So, uh,
I've been stone sober. So yesterday I got
my, uh, my f my first massage in like,
I dunno, like two years. Whenever
I get a massage afterwards,
I always think like, I got
to start doing this, man,
this is great for an old Fart, like
make, you know, and then you come home,
you crush the waters,
you get all the toxins,
adi or whatever yoga shit
they tell you to do. And um,
both the, I know this always have them.
I don't fucking do this. You know what?
Once, once a month I'm going to
go down there, you know? Okay.
Fucking you haven't worked out my
fucking back. Like my whole right.
I don't know what's like,
I have a little curvature of
the spine and the lady's like,
where are the problem areas? Right.
And of course your brain always goes my
dick, but you know, it's illegal place.
Okay,
okay. Yeah.
They seemed to be able to be a problem
in the central pelvic area on the frontal
lobe. Um, I'm like Mike, I never even
noticed it either. I was like, uh,
my right. Yeah. Shoulder,
my right forearm and my right
foot. And I was just like, wow,
how fucked up is my right side?
And then I realized all of them,
all of those injuries I got
from playing drums, you know,
my right forum from fucking
holding this stick wrong.
I don't know what I'm
doing with my shoulders.
Probably after I fuck up another field
looking at the bass player and shrugging
like, I'm sorry. I mean I tried to get
back on one right? And then my foot,
I fucked that up years ago trying to
get my bass drum fast as John Bottoms,
you know, which I never even remotely
achieved. I just had the lifetime pain.
You know,
every time I take a step
I'm always reminded of what
a wonderful drummer jump on
him is. Um, so anyways, uh, I did that.
Um, with the lovely Nia, that's always
a good thing to do it, you know,
you go in there with your wife,
then you don't feel like a dirt bag.
Cause anytime I go to get a massage,
I always feel like a dirt bag.
There's just no way not to feel like a
fucking complete piece of shit when you
walk in there like, yeah, Hey, I want
you to, I want you to work out the kinks.
This we heard, you know
what I mean? Wait a minute.
What am I talking about? I got
a massage and fucking, Nah,
Milwaukee. No, I didn't.
No, I did not. That was a steam.
That was a steam. That's right. Oh,
that's right. That's right. Yeah. I guess
I haven't had like two fucking years.
And they always do the same thing when
they, when they put my hands on my back,
they just go, wow. Wow. Do
you have a lot of stress?
Has it been a while to that guy? Yeah.
Yeah. If your back feels like gravel.
So anyways, we did that and
then we came home and um,
we made a Mario Batali's, a
Lasagna, bowling Aes, and uh,
it was fucking delicious.
Uh, homemade pots,
the homemade pasta things and all that.
I gotta get my homemade pasta game up.
I tried to make the spinach pasta and
this just the pasta was definitely green,
but you could still see the
chunks of a spinach in there.
You know what I mean? So what does that
mean? Did I not need the dough enough?
Was uh, cause it was frozen spinach,
like it's said to be, you know, like the,
uh, the recipe said to be, am I saying
that right? Like the recipe said,
said to be, what the fuck does that
mean? Like the rest he said it should be.
I think that's what I was
trying to say. But um, you know,
when I dried it out and maybe I
just didn't dice it up enough,
I have no idea. But I'm,
I'm actually psyched that a,
the consistency though, I can get
that down. I might've needed it,
needed to need it a little bit more.
I don't know. Is there any, uh,
higher qualified people out there that
could help me out on how to make, uh,
the right Spanish pasta?
Cause I watched some videos and I
still fuck the thing up. But anyways,
so we did all of that and me while I
was watching like the playoff games,
play offs and um,
fucking great games this weekend.
Heartbreakers but just fucking,
just great games with the also that,
that creeping sadness that I always
have when the playoffs are here.
That it's just like, did another
regular season go by that fucking fast.
God Damn it. It's, it's going
to be over. It's another month.
It's going to be fucking over
this time. Next month is good.
This I'm not even going to say cause
it's going to be too fucking depressing.
Um, however,
I have gotten totally into the Celtics
and NBA hoop with my Bruin, so I mean,
I got a little game almost every
night sometimes too. But anyways,
so let's go through them.
Let's go throw him his every fucking do
shoe doesn't like sports is gonna roll
their eyes. Just fast forward like
fucking 40 minutes and you'll be safe. Um,
the first one I saw, I think I
want, I taped all of them. Um,
so I watched them at
weird times. I watched a,
the second half of the original Texas,
the Kansas City chiefs, just absolutely
dominating the, uh, the new Texas.
And I actually tweeted that
out to on a, on Twitter. Um,
and I actually got a ton of
shit for people like, oh,
what are you trying to show off your
sports knowledge? It's like, no,
I like sharing it. I love when people do
stuff like that and I'm a sports nerd.
Okay. I'm not acting like I
played at a professional level.
I just love that shit.
So I'm going to take you through it for
those of you didn't know that the chiefs
are originally called the Texans.
They actually played in Dallas, Texas.
Um, when the AFL first started
and when the AFL first came out,
the NFL,
the established league publicly
laughed at them and said,
these guys are crazy. They'll, this
will never work. Hahaha. Whatever. I,
you know, I, you nervous now are not
nervous at all. We're just going to do,
you know, the American people know
where the quality football is at, right?
That's what they said publicly.
And then behind the scenes as much as
they may or may have not believed that
they then hedge their bets
and they wanted to try to
sabotage the AFL as much as they
could before it even got started.
So the AFL, how many fucking teams did
they have? They had the Boston Patriots,
the buffalo bills, the New York titans.
Yeah.
Uh, the Dallas Texans,
the Minnesota Vikings.
And I'll get back to that before
you say that. I'm wrong on that.
They had the Minnesota Vikings,
I used to know this by heart.
Denver Broncos, Oakland Raiders,
San Diego chargers. I'm sorry,
the Los Angeles chargers.
And uh, dolphins weren't in
it. Bengals weren't in it.
Who the fuck else has left? Bears.
Lions. Yeah, something like that. I,
I probably forgot a team or two. And um,
so the owner with the most
money was Lamar Lundy,
I believe that was his name. I
didn't look the shit up again,
but I read this whole
book on it. Lamar Lundy,
and he was the wealthiest of all owners.
So basically this guy could hold out
the longest in this new crazy venture.
All right. So how, how they
attack the fucking AFL?
They did it on two different levels.
The Dallas Texans were
owned by Lamar Lundy,
the most wealthiest of all the owners.
So what they the NFL did was
they awarded Dallas a team,
which became the Dallas cowboys.
So for a season or two, I forget,
I didn't look it up as I said that you
could either go see the Dallas cowboys or
the Dallas, Texas, now the Dallas cowboys,
as much as they were
an expansion franchise,
you could go down and watch them get
the shit kicked out of them, you know,
by Johnny Unitas, Jim Brown
or you know, Frank Gifford.
And while these guys, you
know, all these legends,
the fucking Green Bay
packers would come to town.
You get to see Vince Lombardi in
the early days of the packers sweep.
You could see all this professional level
talent or you could go across town and
go see the Dallas Texans,
a bunch of nobodies playing a bunch of
nobodies cause they wanna establish it.
So obviously that completely,
um, that's a no brainer.
As a sports fan,
you're going to go see the NFL team and
go see all these stars that you've been
watching on TV. So, uh,
that completely fucked them.
And they had to move to Kansas
City and they became the chiefs.
They kept their color. So, but they
were originally called the Texans,
but they gave up the name. And
then the Minnesota Vikings,
which I did not know. I didn't know
any of that shit till I read the book.
The Minnesota Vikings were
originally going to be an AFL team.
So at the NFL did was not
only award Dallas a team,
they also went to the owners of the
Minnesota Vikings and said, hey,
do you want to just join the NFL
and not be part of the AFL? Come on,
we're an established league.
And of course they said, hey,
fuck you guys and your new venture.
We're going to fuck a fuck the
whole goal and against the NFL,
we're going to join them. So
that's what they did. They uh,
they opened a franchise across town
from the wealthiest owner and then they
stole one of their teams.
That was their two moves as they publicly
laughed at the AFL. So there you go.
There's a little fucking little
little history from all freckles.
Um, and I haven't said that, you
know, maybe they got him back,
but I guess they'd have to beat the
fucking cowboys and are also part of the
NFL. So, uh,
congratulations to the
chiefs and evidently they're
playing the Patriots is what
I got from some of the tweets. And uh,
I am not a comfortable Patriot fan know
Patriot fan who's been watching the
Patriots is, you know, we had a lot of
losses towards the end of the year. Um,
I'm hoping, you know, we're going to get
some help back on our offensive line.
Um, either way it's going to
be, even if we were healthy,
it would have been a brutal
day because, uh, you know,
Andy Reed is no slouch as much as
a guy gets a ton of shit. I mean,
the guy's been to a bunch of, uh, NFC
championship games and shit like that.
He has been there before, but you
know, you do need the players.
You do need the ownership. You need
all of that type of shit to try to, uh,
to try to succeed. So
congratulations to them. And, um,
I am by no means comfortable
with next week. Um,
and you know, also, you know,
the chief speak the Seattle Seahawks
as far as p and the loudest fans at one
point. And they did it in that old
ass stadium rather than the, uh,
the stadium Seahawks fans have that
helps them out and contains the sound
was such a cut, but it's
true. Um, and uh, yeah,
so speaking of the
Vikings and the bangles,
my condolences to fans of
both teams. I've been there,
fortunately you have not been there in
a long time. I guess the Jane's license,
but I can't Wayne as a fan with all the
other shit that was going on. But uh,
Jesus fucking Christ.
What the fuck was that guy doing
after he picked off the ball,
walking up to the tunnel already
celebrating. I don't fucking athletes.
We're superstitious.
The fuck are you doing
okay
right there. Yeah. Right. That's
fucking unbelievable to me.
And then he's fucking sitting there.
He probably already took his God damn
cleats off. And then the very next play,
whatever's it two plays in,
they fumble the fucking ball.
I had to watch this part of the game on
highlights cause I taped the game and
for the one time I don't do
the extended fucking record.
This shit happens and I'm probably gonna
put his cleats on and run back out on
the field and think he was so fucking
frustrated cause he still had champagne,
you know, of course.
And through his veins,
he was already mentally the next week
that he goes, it was the same guy. Right.
Goes in and fucking
knocks out that player.
Unfucking believable.
Yeah.
I'm fucking believable. Hey
Steeler fence. How many years?
Shut the game off after
the interception, Huh? No,
cause you're a fair weather fan.
Just because you couldn't stomach to
watch the Bengal fans jumping up and down
and having some joy. You know, I,
I'd forgive you if you did that.
I'd forgive you if you
walked away. You know,
or if you already started celebrating
and you turn your big fucking sausage
Eaton back to the fucking TV and
you're already doing well when it hey,
but up, but who do we got
next week doing all that shit.
Fucking brutal. And, uh,
the Vikings, I won't even,
I don't even,
can you explain to me how you place
kicker had the laces facing your kicker
twice in one fucking
game and a playoff game?
That's unfucking I've never, I mean,
you never see the laces in, right?
I never even knew about it.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I didn't ever even knew about laces
out since fucking ace Ventura.
That's when I learned about
it. Or is it ace Ventura?
I'm Jesus. Fuck. I mean,
I watched the replay of that game and
I went on Twitter beforehand and I fell
and I found out that vikings
wonder, which a fucking sucked,
but I was in the middle of, you
know, trying to make spinach pasta,
which was well beyond my cooking ability.
So, you know, I was a little fucking,
uh, got a little sideways
there for a minute. And, um,
I was thinking like, what the fuck?
I mean, he must make this feel goal
and then Seattle just has a ridiculous
kickoff return and then they're able to
kick it. Or maybe they score a touchdown
or maybe a defensive back falls down.
I had no idea that he was going
to fucking lose it. Oh my God.
Fucking brutal. But you know what?
Every championship team, you got
to have a little bit of luck.
The first fucking super bowl, the
Patriots won. We had the Tuck rule,
which was a fucking rule. Everybody
blames Tom Brady. It was a blame.
The officials are now there.
The rule rules committee for
coming up with that where we went,
because I say to this day, that's
a fucking fumble. That's a fumble.
The way sugar bear Hamilton
did not interfere with Ken
stay the year the fucking
Raiders won in Superbowl 11.
So anybody in Oakland puts
your fucking hankies away,
cause I don't wanna hear your crying
about it. That was payback for Superbowl.
Uh, not super 11.
The fucking playoffs playoffs in a 77
when sugar bear Hamilton was already in
the air. Jumping at Ken Stabler in the,
and then he lets the ball go and
he called roughing the passer.
And back then it wasn't
a 15 yard penalty. It,
they put the ball where the guy threw
it and it was the end of the game.
He threw a 50 yard fucking prayer.
Ray Hamilton's already in the
fucking air lands on Ken Stabler.
They call roughing the passer and they
took the ball from like the 50 and put it
on the fucking one inch blind and then
the Raiders went and won the fucking
game. So I don't want to
hear anything about it,
but I am man enough to say that the
Tuck rule is fucking horseshit and uh,
I think it's a fumble, you know,
but I'm not expecting that level of
maturity from radar fence, you know,
a fan base that goes to the game,
you know, dressed with, um, you know,
spikes on your shoulder pads that have
been checked by security to make sure
that they're totally safe as you
make a, I'm not safe, angry face.
Um, you know, something that does bug
me. I can't stand when they fucking, um,
when people get upset that Hollywood
has the audacity have awards.
We have awards shows and they always talk
about these self-congratulatory night.
Um, like what business
doesn't have an award show?
It's just not fucking televised. You
know, if you fucking drill for oil,
you know, they had the best
of, you know, BP and all them,
they have their fucking yearly fucking
Christmas party in our best rage and all
manager goes, da Clem.
Clem failed out of fucking Mishawaka clam.
I'm paying for that copper up tonight.
Just kidding. Is his wife here. You know,
they do it and they give
them a little fucking trophy.
They have salesmen or the month
shit. You work at McDonald's,
you can get employee
of the month, you know,
you know they have franchise with
here. You join the fucking cub scouts,
you tie your fucking shoes,
they give you a little badge to
sow and your fucking shirt, right?
Yeah.
Why isn't Hollywood allowed to
have their little fucking evening?
What is it? Huh? What is it that bugs you?
That there's a bunch of
hot famous ass there?
Okay.
Oh, Geez. I'm sorry.
You only want to see,
I want to see somebody go out there and
defend bill Cosby on an award show dead
serious and just fucking hold it and
never let anybody in on the joke and then
try to continue hosting
into it in the monologue.
Let's see if they ask you back. All right,
I'm done being a cunt. Um, Pat's
verse, Kansas City. No, I'm not. Oh,
this is the one I want to fucking
read here. I want to read a,
the live reads advertising.
All right. Dollar Shave Club.
Every $1 shave club. Uh,
lots of players will be sporting
playoff beards. Now that, oh,
now that the post seasons here,
leave that to the pros kickoff a
year, right, with a fresh blade.
That's why a millions of others have
joined dollar Shave club.com dollar shave
club knows the key to
getting the amazing shave.
What the key to getting
amazing shave is simple one,
use a fresh dollar shave club blade
to use their Dr Covey's easy shave.
That's it.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing razors
right to my door for a third of the
price of those greeting
mega razor corporations.
That means listeners who switch now
can afford the luxury of shaving with a
fresh blade any time and
save hundreds this year.
And when you combine that fresh blade
with their doctor, Covey's easy shave,
it just glides. It's unimaginably
smooth. I'm telling you,
it's not your average shave foam and it
won't dry out your skin, which is great.
The all natural ingredients. Leave
your skin feeling soft, smooth,
and moisturize even after the
shape. Uh, take it from me.
Use a fresh doll shape called blade
with Dr Carver's. Easy shave butter.
One time I had to do the hours. Um,
if you want the most gentle shave
imaginable joint, the dollar shave
club.com/bar revolution today, that's
dollar shave club.com/per. All right,
blue apron. All right. You need to know
how to cook that only. Well, I mean,
if you want to be healthy, you need
to know how to cook. All right,
Jesus Blue Apron. You're coming
right out with the generalities. Um,
not only do you feel like you
know your way around the kitchen,
but cooking at home means eating healthier
and saving money instead of ordering
expensive takeout again.
Uh, but where do you start?
Blue Apron has you covered
for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all the fresh
ingredients you need to create home cooked
meals. Just follow the easy
step by step instructions.
Each meal can be prepared in 40
minutes or less. No more overwhelming,
overwhelming trips to the grocery
store. No more sad take out. Plus,
you know what's great is if you
know you're dating some chicken,
she doesn't know. You know,
you're dating some guy the fuck you
doing and they don't know that you don't
know shit in the kitchen. You know,
you whip this fucking thing together.
They look at this. Maybe
somebody I can be with, you know,
if you're looking for a relationship
or maybe somebody they could fuck, um,
each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the grocery
store. No more said takeouts.
I already read that. No matter
your dietary preferences,
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to
discover and prepare dishes like
Blahblahblahblahblah right now in
your kitchen. Cook with ingredients,
okay.
Um, Cook with ingredients that you've
never used before. Like watermelon,
radishes, I've never even
heard of that. Pharaoh, Farro,
f Arro and purple potatoes and
recipes between 500 to 700 calories.
Proportions. Delicious
and good for you. Do this.
If you're fucking working
out trying to get shaped,
this is fucking perfect right now.
You can get your first two meals
for free at blue apron.com/burger.
That's blue apron.com/bar hi
blue apron.com/pur blue apron.
A better way to cook. You know, it'd
be great even if even if you, you know,
have a nine to five regular job, if
you start off with a decent breakfast,
you bring your fucking lunch and then
you ordered a blue apron at night and you
all know, why did I see y'all? Y'All are,
y'all know what I'm talking about? Um,
dinner is what fucks you
diet, at least for me,
cause I can eat well the whole fucking
day. Whole Day, I'm doing good,
I'm doing good. And then by fucking
four o'clock, I'm like, Hey,
I want some fucking potato chips
and I want some ice cream. You know,
if you can just fucking call these cuts
and have them deliver a 500 700 a meal
and you just fucking eat the
shit, right. And then you're done.
Drink waters for the rest of the night
and have a little salary already cut up,
you know, throw a spoonful of
peanut butter in there. You know,
it's going to melt off unless
you have, you know, I don't know.
Some built in excuse, you know, like
a lot of overweight people do. Oh Man.
Metabolism's really slow. Yeah, yeah.
That and 8,000 calories a fucking day,
dude. Alright. MV Empty
watches. Oh, you know,
we only have four. This week's, why
don't I do two and two? Let's do that.
All right, let's get back to
the thing here. Um, all right.
Uh, oh today as I'm rushing
through this fucking podcast,
um, I'm having somebody coming
over looking at my garage today,
I even have to whisper this shit.
I somehow talked my wife into, uh,
you know,
allowing me to have just have somebody
come over and take a look at the garage.
And I know I did that a couple months
back, but then I got busy but now I,
I got the person coming back again and uh,
I'm actually using her skills,
you know, that she does with me.
That's how I ended up with the dog.
Like we're not getting this dog.
We just were a fostering the dog for a
couple of days cause she knew that I'd
fallen in love with the fucking
dog and then that would be yet.
So it's kind of like when you first
start start dating a woman, um,
you know, when she wants a relationship,
when she comes over to your apartment,
which she starts to do,
is she leave shit there cause it
gives her an excuse to come back.
I mean it's fucking nuts, right? Like
they're thinking that far ahead. All,
you're sitting there like, oh, look
at those dirt or the fucker. Right.
That's all you're thinking. And
they're sitting there plotting,
you know what I mean?
It's like you're some fucking head coach
that has no game plan and she's across
the field like fucking Bill Walsh calling
the first 25 plays of the game. Right?
Oh, I love a football life. There's
a nice reference to use. Um,
so, you know, it's fucking hilarious.
And speaking with the Patrice O'Neal
benefits coming up, once again, uh,
I'll tell you a quick Patrice story. Um,
he was so fucking brilliant that I
remember he was dating this woman and you
know, uh, whatever,
seeing her and she started leaving
shit around his house and I,
and it just had brought that up. I go,
yeah, you know, I did this for me. No,
she left this shit here and she left
there. It's like, what the fuck? You know,
I only see you like, you know, once
every two weeks. He just has shit there.
So for two weeks I keep looking at her
fucking brush or the shampoo she left or
whatever. And it's just, I keep
thinking about it and it's annoying me
and Patrice just goes,
Ecos, so throw it out.
I go, what? He goes, throw it out. I
go, I can't throw it a brush. He goes,
I would like, go get the fuck out.
He goes, yeah. He goes, I did that.
They told me a story. Well,
there was a woman he was messing around
with and she left these toiletries and a
little bag of like, you know,
makeup and brush and all that eddy.
He fucking threw it out.
And then he came back like a week and
a half later and she goes to go in the
bathroom and she's like
a, she's like, Hey,
what did you do with my a my stuff? He
goes, and he just plays dumb. He goes,
what stuff? She goes, I left shampoo
here, I a little makeup bag. He goes,
Oh yeah, I was yours. Yeah. He goes, yeah.
He threw it out and she was
like literally beside herself,
but actually on some level respected him
for like fucking realizing what she was
doing.
And then also I think because that early
on he clearly let her know in a very
funny fucking way that he wasn't
looking for a relationship and uh,
that she was able to relax and
kind of be thinking that, oh,
we're just fucking all right. I wanted
a little more, he doesn't at least,
but he let us know so fucking early
on that it didn't really hurt,
you know? Does that make sense? I mean,
I don't, maybe I'm speaking for her,
but I guess I am, but whatever. Either
way it was fucking funny, you know,
Jesus was that the fucking worse.
I literally just jumped out of the plane
and pulled the fucking ripcord on that
story. Sorry. It's been a while.
It's been a while since I told that
story as it, I have, I told it before.
I don't fucking know. So anyways,
so I'm kind of using, um, my,
the same fucking tricks that my wife used
that got me the dog I'm using with her
because, um, we're gonna like, hey,
why am I whispering here? Like,
she can't just listen to the fucking
podcast fucking he that sometimes like how
dumb I am. It just really
fucking, so anyways,
what I want to do is I have this
old school fucking, you know,
my house is built in 1923 so the garage
whenever it was fucking built was built,
um,
to house like a fucking model t Ford
kind of car and those things for those
things, you sat inside the fucking wheel
wells, you know what I mean? If you,
if you look at old cars, um,
you know how the fenders used to flare
out and then there was just the engine
and you know,
you sat like literally like
right behind basically what you,
you sat in the, I can't, I don't know
if I, if I'm explaining correctly,
you know what I mean? You sitting inside
the fucking wheel wheel wells, right?
Not like literally in them,
but as far as like the line
down the side of the car, right.
Like if you stuck your head out and
you didn't have any fenders on it,
you'd be looking at the fucking
tire. Right. As opposed to, you know,
the fucking road. I know all you
guys know what I'm talking about.
And it also goes to show you like how
fucking fat and big people have gotten,
you know what I mean? Two things.
If you ever go to Mount Vernon and you
go to Thomas Jefferson's house and you
have to duck underneath
the fucking, uh, the, uh,
the fuck, do you come the doorframes
you see how much taller people are.
And then when you look at
those old fucking cars,
the fact that two adults could sit side
by side like that and it wouldn't be
the, probably won't even touching
each other, you know. So anyways,
what I'm trying to say is that my, uh,
my garage is long and skinny
and it's like high up,
you know, and uh,
and then it kind of flares out at the
back as it kind of wraps around the back
of the house a little
bit. So what I wanna do,
the front part is long enough for
me to squeeze my truck in there.
Um, but then in the back,
what I want to do is I want to
turn that into like a little gym,
which my wife has all four. And then
I'm also pitching that I build the,
maybe a little drum room
that could actually,
I got this drum kit that I bought that
I have in cases that if I want to play
it, I have to throw it in the truck
and drive it down to a studio.
I'm thinking of making, building
like a room within a room,
which will add no value to
the house unless I someday
sell it to another fucking
drummer who also whispers
on his own fucking podcasts.
Like his wife can't hear it. Fuck it.
I'm still whispering. You know why?
You know why?
Because the guys coming in like a half
hour and my wife is asleep downstairs.
If she hears me yelling about it,
I might have to have this argument sooner
than I'm prepared to have it. So, um,
that is the game plan. And like a
couple months back I bought those colds.
Um, you know, all those things like
though that American Ninja Shit,
so down downstairs in the garage,
I want to just have those hanging from
the ceiling so I can do all of that grip
strength shit that I want to
get better at. By the way,
I fucking started working out for the
first time in forever and I went to Duke.
Go do pullups. Holy Shit. I
literally felt like as like,
do I have sandbags in my pockets?
What the fuck's going on?
I did six good ones and whimpered through
the last four. I always try to do 10.
I can't even fucking do
it. It's pathetic. Um,
so that's like the big exciting
thing in my life right now.
And I got to kind of get
this thing going, um,
before my wife wakes up and find
something else to do in the house.
You know, maybe, I don't know.
So anyways, by the way, people,
I'm doing a Gig in a Vancouver,
I'm doing a Gig in Vancouver,
uh, Canada this Sunday
night, alas, second one.
That was added because I left my January
open because I'm still waiting to hear
about a season two.
We meet with Netflix this week to
pitch them our ideas for season two.
Uh, so if you've already
watched F is for family.
I thank you so much cause you've got
me to at least getting the meeting.
So we'll see a, we will see what
happens. It's um, with that and um,
so I hadn't booked
anything, um, in January.
So now we're having some last
second gigs, um, coming up.
I'm going to do a Gig in Vancouver this
Sunday and then I'm going to do a couple
of dates, one or two dates I think right
before the Patrice O'Neal benefit, um,
in the tristate area. We're still,
I'm trying to fucking iron those
things out as we speak. Jesus Christ.
Bill, spit it out. All right, let's get
to the, uh, the questions of this week.
Uh, all right. Inbox, inbox, inbox.
Where's the content? Here's the
con. No, I had it on the other page.
What am I doing? Oh there we go. All
right, Bill Patriots first. Kansas City.
Hello there. Mr. Bird. How's it going?
Your freckled cut there. How are Ya?
Uh, hope your holidays were just
peachy. Same to Cleo and Nia. Uh,
today I just wanted to hear your honest
and objective thoughts about the matchup
between your paths and
my chiefs this weekend.
I was just listening to
your podcast from 12,
seven 15 we'll you said
Casey won't when Shit,
somebody tweeted me that I said
that I talked so much trash.
I don't even remember saying that. Uh,
and I'm content that you may eat those
words this week. Oh, absolutely. Oh,
I absolutely might eat those words
this week. Uh, but having said,
I think I might, what
Casey, what, when Shit is,
you're not gonna win the Super Bowl.
That's what I mean. My pick is, uh,
the Seattle Seahawks,
which is not really a,
it's not really a genius pics
by any stretch of the means.
They've been there two fucking
years in a row. Um, I mean,
didn't they win yesterday
without Marshawn Lynch?
I was running back and forth
trying to make lasagna noodles. Uh,
as far as I know, I didn't
see Marshawn lynch in there.
My wife was also clicking back and forth
to like the fucking Golden Globes. So,
um, I just know that they,
uh, now when I wait, that was,
that was the earlier one. Do,
do you know yesterday I watched,
I watched fucking Ohio state, Indiana.
I watched two playoff football games
and I watched half of a Celtic game and
fell asleep was fucking ridiculous.
So I'm trying to remember what the
fuck I saw this weekend. But, um, no,
I don't think it's going to be an easy,
uh, listen, I've got to tell you this.
If we were fucking healthy, we would
kick the shit out of you. All right?
If we actually had an offensive line and
Edelman was back and Amygdala was back,
we had a fucking running game and
a way we, we've, we were healthy.
This is no fucking contest at home.
You know it and I know it right now,
Brady is driving a fucking rental car.
So you might go in there and beat us
and then you're going to get all fucking
excited and loud. And then, you
know what? I don't know. You know,
why would I root against you guys?
Hey, you know what, you guys, heck,
you guys haven't won since
what? 1970 all right.
What was that? Uh, what was
that fucking Hank stream call
power trap. Cross 57 five nine five.
What the fuck was that thing called?
I don't remember. You guys have an
a. When you beat the fucking Vikings,
Jesus Christ going way
back. You beat the AFL team.
That fucking sold up. Maybe
that's why they're cursed.
Maybe that's why they've lost one or
they lose three, three, four Superbowls.
Three Superbowls. Right? They
lost to the fucking chiefs.
They lost to the packages.
They lost to the dolphins.
Any loss to the Steelers. Is that right?
Wait, the dolphins lost to the cowboys.
Then they beat the vikings
and they beat the Redskins.
That's right. She speak the vikings.
Green Baby. The chiefs.
They didn't beat the Raiders, did
they? They beat the Vikings. Right now.
The Vikings would have been in the NFL
by then. I don't fucking or whatever.
You lost like fucking three of
them. Maybe because you'd get,
you didn't stick with the AFL
guys. Does that make any sense?
Whatever. Good luck to the chiefs this
week. A good luck to the Patriots.
Obviously my heart is with the Patriots,
but uh, you know, I don't know.
I didn't like, like that dolphins
game where every time Brady,
the few times he went back to past,
there was just somebody right in
his grill every fucking time. Um,
but whatever the end of the fucking day,
we have the greatest fucking quarterback
and coach of all fucking time.
So go fuck yourself. I think
we're gonna beat you. All right.
It'd be no fun if I said good luck
to you guys. So fuck you guys.
You don't stand a chance
there. Now if you beat me,
you got something to talk about,
then he could trash me and I can fill
out a fucking hour next week on the
podcast. Um, alright. Drive
to school. Oh, by the way,
Alabama. Clemson, I have no, I
don't know shit about either team.
I was so fucking busy in the fall.
I didn't get to watch any of it,
but of course, um, I, I
wouldn't care if Alabama won,
but Clemson hasn't won in a while, so
I'd love to see them win. However, if,
if Alabama wins, it just makes
the Cleveland Brown's futility even
funnier to me because the dumbest fucking
move ever.
Do you realize that they
had bill Belichick and Nick
Saban coaching their team
and they fired them?
Okay.
The VUS, the fucking Paul Brown,
Vince Lombardi of the modern day
NFL and the Paul Brown bear Bryant,
Vince Lombardi,
okay.
Of NCAA Division One football.
They had them both coaching together
and they fired the CEO of
Alabama. As a Cleveland Brown fan,
you have to be rooting for
Clemson. You just have to,
you guys have had enough
fucking pain. Right? Who knows?
Maybe Lebron can get you over
the hump this year, you know, uh,
I always root for Cleveland. Like
I said, I have relatives, you know,
family that grew up out there
and all that type of shit. I, uh,
actually love Cleveland. So, um,
however, I also love a good joke.
So if Alabama wins tonight,
it'll still be funny. Anyways,
continue on drive to school. Hey Bill,
I've been a fan of yours since
the ona days and Chappelle show.
Somewhere along the line I had a kid
and he's old enough to listen to some of
your podcasts. Uh, I listened to
it with him on the drive to school.
I listened to the whole episode before
beforehand and cut out any of the stuff
that is a bit heavy or sexual. Uh,
Jesus, you're fucking great dad.
When you start editing their content,
you know, look at you, you're a regular,
typical a not because I'm sheltering him,
but because he and I don't need,
don't need share certain podcasts
moments. When you talk of Ges in uh,
in some skank before 8:00 AM exactly.
Let the kid have a childhood, uh,
trying to keep it light and positive
with the exception of the funny negative.
Anyways, I wanted to tell you that
it's the best thing we got going.
We listened to about 15 minutes a day.
It puts him and I in a laughing mood,
which he needs schools,
a lot of work these days.
And he always got a ton of homework and
projects and his dragon in the morning.
This wakes him up.
Sometimes we pause and talk about certain
things or I'll explain certain stuff
to him about politics, sports, et
cetera. Yeah. In other words, correct.
The dumb shit that I said,
all that father son stuff.
Thanks for the parental
assist. Oh, that's great.
Who would ever thought my
ignorance could be had? Warman
uh, anyways, uh,
I'm already regretting fucking making
funny Ricky Gervais' why did I do that
shit? But you know, I mean, he's
making fun of everybody on the show.
It's only fair, right.
Does showing up with fucking acceptance
speeches and he's got all those fucking
zingers at him and his writing
staff wrote, it's only fair.
That's why I like Mel Gibson.
Mel Gibson gave him shit back.
I don't understand why people
just go out and smiling.
They should fucking trash them.
A vasectomy. Ah, dear bill,
I don't want to get a
vasectomy. I just don't.
My wife and anyone else who chimes in
on this subject started trying to break
down positives and point out
the lack of negatives ever.
Just not want something.
I just don't want one.
Can you believe this or you with everyone
else that it must be rooted in some
fear, et cetera. Fuck
that dude. Fuck that.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Do you think you could fucking tell a
woman what the fuck to do with their body
for two seconds before she just said
you're a, you're a chauvinistic cunt.
Yeah, Dude. Fuck that.
Fuck that all day long.
That's your fucking Dick and
balls. All right. You got that.
They fuck with your Dick.
If you don't fucking want them
to go in there and snip, snip,
whatever the fuck I've even looked up
the operation, I still don't get it.
I don't get it. Nothing comes out.
So does it stop your
ability to make choices?
Do they put an utter down there where
you got to milk the ges out as well?
That's disgusting. I don't get, I
don't get what happens, but fuck that.
Fuck that. Fuck that. Just just
sit down with you. I say, listen,
I don't want to do that. And she'll be
like, why? Why not you? You're just,
you're just fear based.
It's like, no it isn't.
I don't want to be walking
around and like, dude,
you know what that's like.
You like a muscle car and they want to
rip the engine out and put a fucking v6
in there. Fuck you and keep you a
Shelby badge on the side of your car.
And every day in the morning you wake
up standing there looking at yourself
after you got out of the shower knowing
that it's a lie. Fuck that dude.
Fuck. Do you keep the bullets in that
gun? Alright, she can't handle it.
You know I, you know, what
is she going to do to you?
Huh? She gonna hold you down and make
while someone else does it just, yeah,
you don't want one dude.
You don't want one to the level you're
reaching out to a fucking podcast.
Okay. Do you understand that? Would
even use that in your argument?
Just be like, but I don't play this
audio though. I would just say, listen,
I so do not want to do this
that I actually wrote into
a podcast to get advice.
That's how much I don't want to do this.
And then she'll just be like, well,
maybe we need to go
talk somebody about it,
which means she's going to set up an
appointment with somebody who agrees with
her. Okay. All right. Cause she's going
to set up the appointment call. Listen,
my husband needs to get a
vasectomy. He's very nervous.
He says he doesn't want to get it,
but it's gotta be the best for us and
she's going to totally set the fucking
table. It's like those dumb
fucks that go on, Doctor Phil,
do you have a c those said sacks that
go on that fucking show with their wife.
Like they have a fucking prayer
doctor. Phil's audience is women.
So he's going to have to side with the
woman every fucking time. Even if he,
you know, he's going
to try that, you know,
hide his hand and give
her a little bit of Shit.
But at the end of the day he's
going to be looking at you go,
you need to get your balls snipped right.
He's got to come at you like that
while he sits there, you know,
with his junk still fucking work. You
know, he's got a giant fucking unit.
Doesn't he do that big fucking Goof, that
big bold goof. Walk it down the hall.
I, you know, he's got a fucking
giant fucking unit. Big Greg.
Great Dane balls. I don't know why.
I think he's got a fucking giant
unit. He does. He's just like,
he's just dirt. But the
way he talks, he's just,
God always gives them big dicks.
It just, I don't know what it is.
Um,
well the giant size 16 brown wooden
wingtips just sitting across from you.
That's gotta be the worst fucking
show ever to be on. Oh my God.
I never thought about doctor Phil's junk
before you see that it takes somebody
to fucking bring up a vasectomy, you'll
never be able to think about them again.
Megan, my big Dick say, you
need to listen to your wife.
All right. Jumping out
of a plane. Hey Bill,
where are you at on
jumping out of a plane? Uh,
if you're a chicken shit
American, I'm a Brit.
How much money would it take you to jump?
Uh,
I got a bet with my mate that you hate
heights and it take 500,000 US dollars.
Don't change your answer to be contrary
to what I just guess. Keep it fair.
Good sir. Thanks a Jesus.
Another arrogant Brit.
These guys think they're
fucking geniuses. Um,
I've already done it. You fucking
idiot. And I paid someone to do it.
Paid. I went to a in Pepperell,
Massachusetts when I was 19 years old
and I didn't do a tandem jump either.
I did a static line jump. I've told
this story on the podcast, sir,
if you're a little bit, um, more up on it.
Uh, and also I have a pilot's
license. I fly helicopters.
So if I afraid of heights,
I mean I'm afraid of heights. Look,
if I don't have a parachute on my
back and I'm not in a, in a, uh,
in a vehicle that's designed to fly, okay,
then yes, I'm afraid of
heights. Like, I don't like, uh,
you know, like if he should,
like one time I watched the youtube video
and they just showed these guys that
had the climb up to the top
of this fucking building
and then,
no, no claims. That was it. They took
the elevator, who's getting hope? They,
they, they were on the roof and it
was already on the fucking roof.
This building was so fucking
high up and you know,
the wind up there must be ridiculous.
I would literally just lay down in the
fetal position and crawl back to the
fucking door that leads to the stairwell,
reach up to the handle and
fucking go back down. But this,
this dude, um,
then climbs the fucking, the, the,
the whatever though though the radio tower
or whatever and it just keeps getting
higher and higher and higher in the tower
gets smaller and smaller and smaller
and he's hooking and unhooking
his safety line. I literally,
I couldn't find,
I mean obviously the guy lives cause it's
his GoPro on his helmet and I've never
been so fucking unsettled watching
something in my life. Okay.
Then I would hate heights. But I think
at that point everybody hates heights.
But, um, yeah, when I was 19 years
old, I went to a, this place,
uh, in Pepperell, Massachusetts,
which I don't think exists anymore.
They might still be an airport
there and they had a, a, a school.
And uh, I did the static line jump,
if you've ever seen that movie,
a Fandango when Kevin
Costner's earlier ones
were the dude from a breakfast
club, uh, Judd Nelson,
his character jumps out.
Okay.
Um, that's exactly what I did.
And I remember when we went up,
the command was sit in the door, get out,
and then he slapped you on
the shoulder and said, go.
And uh,
I remember when he said sit in the door.
I thought he was saying close the door.
So I was reaching up, I'm sitting down,
reaching out, trying to close the door,
and he had this big smile on his face.
Like he thought I was chickening out.
I feel like I just told this story on
the podcast and then if I really thought
he was saying, sit in the door.
So you sit in the door and basically
it's one of those planes where the,
the wing is above the aircraft.
Do you know what I mean?
It's on top of the aircraft
as opposed to below,
which actually gives you a much
better site I would think. Um,
as far as if you wanted to look down. Um,
and then there's the support that
goes to the side of the plane. So,
and then right above one
of the landing wheels,
the wheels don't retract on this plane.
They had a welded, a little step.
So you sat the fucking door
and a, I forget how high we were at
going to say we will only like 1500.
We weren't that high up because you
shoot immediately comes out. Um,
so you said you sit in the door,
then he goes get out and then what you
do is you reach out and you grab that
support beam from the wing and you hold
onto that while one of your feet is,
uh, is standing on that little step
thing. And then basically what you do is,
I'm literally acting this out so I can
remember it, is you then basically you,
you bend your arms and
you bring your chest,
like flush with the support
beam and then the, the,
the foot that's dangling, you
put it straight out behind you.
It's almost like a yoga pose. So
it was sit in the door, get out,
and then he slaps your shoulder
and he goes, go and you let go.
And then you, you arch you arc,
right? Arc One arc, 1002, 1003,
1000. Look, if nothing look reached
Paul. And when you're looking,
you're looking over your, your
shoulder to see if you shoot came out.
And then if nothing you
looked down at the handle,
reach, pull it. Cause for some reason
they say if you don't look down,
you might be flailing
because you're panicking.
Cause it's the first time you jumped
in, the shoot didn't come out. Sorry.
Cayenne pepper Ra. Hang on a second.
So anyways, I get out,
he goes, go, I let go. And
instead of arching ice,
I don't know what I did. I
just reached for something.
All I know is I started doing front foot
front flips as my shoop was coming out
and I felt it go by my
leg, the inside of my leg,
I felt it go by my leg.
I felt something hit that and I was
immediately thinking, oh my God,
I'm going to roll right up
in this fucking thing. Like,
you know when you put Bacon on shrimp
and a the second I had that thought like
the shoot already had come out.
And by the grace of God
I didn't get tangled up.
I think about that sometimes. Like
how easily I could have fucking died.
Um, and then boom, your shoot comes
out and when you shoot comes out,
you don't even feel like you're falling
because there's nothing going past you.
Cause you're above the
treeline and all that.
So you just feel like you just
sort of suspended in the air.
And uh, there was a radio and this
lady just talked to you and she say,
pull the left toggle and you had to
pull it all the way down to your knee.
Cause I remember there was this,
this big girl in the class and she
couldn't get it around her hips and she
landed across the street in a pile
of loom in a dislocated her knee.
I remember that before. And then I went
up after her and I was just like, fuck.
Um, and then they have this ridiculous,
you know when you get to the treeline
you suddenly realize how fast you're
falling. I think it was like 17
feet per second or maybe 11 feet.
I can't remember. But it was really
fast. It was like basically, you know,
jumping off of a, of a basketball
rim. Like how fast you'd come down.
It had to be a little bit
slower, right? No, no.
Cause you're not reaching terminal
velocity. I don't fucking know.
So all I know is when you hit the ground,
where you were supposed to do is look
straight ahead because for some reason if
you look down at your feet,
what you were going to do,
they were worried you'd pick your feet
up too quickly and somehow break your
legs.
So what you had to do is look straight
ahead and as right as you hit the ground,
you supposed to do this little fucking
like collapsed down and then this big
ridiculous,
bring your both your legs straight up
in the air and then over to your side.
I don't know why. I doubt that they
still have people do that. And I did.
What everybody else did is I came down
and the second my feet hit the ground,
I did a face plant right into the
grass and my buddy grabbed the,
uh, the Mike from the person who called
me a Dickhead, something like that.
What a dick hit or something in
the um, in the, in the radio.
Um, so yeah, there you go. So I did it.
And what are you basing chicken
shit. American not, Huh? Oh,
you tough guys over there with your
fish and chips. Have you done it yet?
500 euros. I, there's nothing you can
sub. If I don't want to do something,
I wouldn't do it. There's not money that
you can give me and all. He goes, oh,
you fuck a break now I'm making
great money. I got enough money,
I got enough money. I'm good to take
my life in my fucking hands. Now.
That's one of those things. Now, I was
back working at the warehouse. I mean,
granted I pay somebody when I was
working in a fucking warehouse, I a shit,
you know, let's see. How much would
they, I mean, if they gave me,
literally, if you gave me $400, you
would've doubled my pay for the week.
So I would have done
that. Well, let's see,
let's go back to the building
to climb up dead building.
How much money would
they have to give me a,
when I was working in
the warehouse, uh, $800.
Um,
and that now for that, that
building, uh, I would say, uh,
yeah, I just wouldn't do it. That's,
no, I'm all right. I'm all set.
I'm all set. I, you know, I should
actually send you guys dead video.
Um,
so it's not that I hate
heights, sir. I hate,
I'm risking my life to that level.
If there's like a parachute
or something like that,
it is a bungee cord or there's like
a fucking safety line, that's fine.
But you know,
going up that tower where I have to unhook
the safety line and then hook it back
up and there's wind and shit. Fuck
that. That's too much of a risk.
I wouldn't do that.
You know? Fuck.
Why do I even want to fucking talk
about college cooking dear Billy boy.
Oh, that's a great one. What a great
one. Bill. Billy Paul. Yeah. D.
Oh fuck. I gotta wrap this up. This
guy's coming in 12 minutes. Uh,
I'm sure everyone is blowing you
up to make another cooking video,
so don't worry. This isn't
that I'm a college student.
I know you've lived like a college
student into your early thirties.
From past stories about living
with Bobby Kelly. Oh Dude.
We weren't living like college students.
We will live in like fucking animals.
Uh, do you have any menu
suggestions besides pasta?
What would you mix together? I'm pretty
current creative, and I do all right,
but I'm open to some suggestions.
What's good to throw together on a
budget and on a fly. You know what dude?
I would go to, um, I would,
this is what I would do.
I would go on Youtube and I would ask
that question and you'll find videos and
then just start searching.
And at some point you're going to connect
with somebody. And I feel like I'm,
you know, dropping the ball here on
the question, but like I'm not a chef.
I'm not even a cook. I'm really
early on this to this myself.
So that's what I would do. There's
a bunch of old episodes of Mario,
Mario Batali's, multiple
Mario, m. O. L. T. O, Mario.
Um, I really suggest watching
those. Just watch the guy.
I used to just watch the
show and just by watching it,
you learn things and you start
to see how things are made. Um,
and, and, uh, the big thing is
not having, you just have to, to,
to learn shit in life. You got to have
the, the mindset of like, I'm gonna,
you know, I'm going to fuck
this up probably the first time.
And that's all right. And then I'll get
a little better like the pasta already.
Just even just running it through the
pasta maker. I already have like three,
three fucking things that I'm not
going to do the next time. Um,
and by the way, somebody
gave me a great tip when you,
after you find needed the dope and
you put it through your pasta maker,
be sure to douse like both sides with
flour, be liberal with the flour.
Cause if you don't it's going to tear.
It could tear when you're in there cause
it's supposed to be like sticky and
elastic at the same time. And uh,
when you run it through there,
um, yeah you could,
you could possibly have some issues and
it tears then it's a big fucking pain in
the ass. And then he gets sad. You feel
like a fucking failure and you're not,
he had the balls to
try it. So I would, uh,
I go that Rachel Ray's got a great bunch
of great ones from back in the day.
Everybody always makes fun of
her, but she wouldn't, she,
I made 20 minute meals. He did
little fucking lab. She'd do.
I used to watch your shit all the time.
That's great shit for
probably where you're at.
But I would also Google
some stuff like that. Um,
but it's great as a college student,
if you start to learn how to cook,
if you start to learn how to cook
right now and you do it religiously,
you are going to be a beast
compared to the average person.
Um, by the, by the time you're in
your thirties, dude, forget it.
If you add like shit,
like learning how to,
how to make a pie crust cause then
then you can make Turkey pot pie.
You can make key, she can
make all of this shit.
You start making homemade pasta.
Forget it. It's fucking over.
Then you learn how to do all this
other stuff. I forget what I mean.
I made it with Nia. I was really
concentrating on making the pasta.
She did the bowl and Aes and then
she did the whole milk sauce thing,
but I just was watching her do that
where you heated up some butter and some
flour and then he heated up some milk.
Then you poured the whole thing together
instead of using like a ricotta cheese,
um, or any of that type of shit. Um,
you use this really rich milk
thing. It was almost too much.
The fucking dish was like, it
almost tasted like a dessert.
It was so fucking good. But, um,
I didn't know how to do
shit when I was your age.
So I think it's great that
you're doing it. Um, you know,
you want, how about Blue Apron?
Sign up for that shit and just, you know,
steal some of their meal ideas and
then expand on them. If there's a,
or if there's a style of
cooking that they give you,
then you go on Youtube and, uh,
you just start looking at recipes
about that. Like, you know what, I,
I don't know anything about,
which is weird because I loved the
food is any sort of Asian style, um,
cooking. I actually smoked some
ribs and I, and I had this, uh,
this dipping sauce that was like,
oh, uh, you know, whatever, uh,
Chinese or Japanese influenced, you know,
with the fucking soy sauce
and all that. And it was,
and I was in a part of the grocery
store that I never went to.
And it was the shit. It
tasted great. And, um,
that's something I was
kinda thinking this year.
I want to get down pasta and
start to have some Asian, uh,
type dishes in there.
So if there's anybody out there that can
help me with that, I'd appreciate it.
So anyways, the guys coming here in eight
minutes, I get to upload this fucker.
Um, I'll talk to you later.